[Music]
let's go to cr kirsten in denver
colorado i almost didn't read i'm sorry
what's up
it's okay i get it a lot uh not much how
are you dr john partying rocking on i'm
not partying
it's the morning i'm not that cool
what's up
um so my question for you is how do i
stop worst case scenario thinking um and
be present in the moment without
discounting hard things that happen
so that usually means a thing happened
what was it
um so
my husband and i have been married for
about two and a half years and
um
i'm 29 okay
um and my husband right before christmas
was diagnosed with cancer oh jeez
wow
what kind of cancer
bladder cancer oh my gosh i'm so sorry
uh thanks
so
um i'm i'm really trying to
as we sort of like go through this weird
process to
like not
spiral
out of control with my thoughts and
worst case scenarios but also like
this is really hard and
i i just i don't know how to not let my
anxiety get out of control without like
also acknowledging and
that like this is this is hard and
that um
like this is happening and not just be
pollyanna about it and you know like oh
everything's gonna be fine because it
might not be right so what's what's the
what's the update right now
um so everything happened really really
fast and so i feel like we're still
really processing it so um like within a
couple of weeks of being diagnosed he um
had surgery to take the tumor out and he
had a round of chemotherapy
um and so
they um
they got
they they got everything out and they
they did that round of chemo and so now
every three months he goes back in for
more testing to make sure that nothing's
growing back
um so right now there's there's no
there's no proof that cancer is there
there's no proof that cancer's there no
we're just like watching for side
effects
and we're watching for like
for symptoms of it um
like uh there's a whole bunch of things
we have to watch for sure um and if we
see him then we have to call the
urologist and all of that
but every three months for the next two
years he'll go back in for
um for
tests to see if anything's come back
all right so i'm going to speak super
directly probably in a way that nobody's
spoken with to you is that okay
yeah because i'm your friend and i love
you and you're we're
we're neighbors now cool
okay
he might die
and then there's a period
right so there's a period at the end of
that sentence
and the next sentence is
statistically speaking he's probably not
going to
period at the end of that sentence right
and every three months your body is
going gonna gear up to protect you
because you love him with everything
and that's okay if you weren't nervous
for these three month appointments i
would tell you to go see somebody right
away
that just means that you love him and
that you want him to be okay and that
when he's okay you're okay and if he's
not okay you're not okay that's what
that means yeah it's just your body
trying to love you okay so it's gonna
sound crazy let it
right so let it okay
you got to peek behind the curtain
that most of us don't ever get to peek
behind which is this we have this
illusion that we all get 93 years with
each other
yeah and then somebody
came into your house banging a cowbell
and you got to see behind the curtain
you're like oh this could go away at any
second
right
yep so your body's just trying to take
care of you because it loves you
so here's the here's the moving forward
part okay
has anyone let me pause here for a
second i know that's heavy
has anyone said out loud he might die
not out loud no okay so let's put it out
there one of the things that's really
important for our bodies is to put this
stuff out there otherwise it starts
solving for these problems and it moves
its own
it moves the finish line on itself over
and over and over again
what i mean by that is
you have this overwhelming sense of doom
this and then you go to webmd and it's
for sure it's telling you everyone's
dying right oh yes everyone's dying um
and then you have this over the shadow
that's just laying over you and so we go
to the internet we go to facebook go to
pinterest or whatever trying to solve
this thing
the solution comes from saying out
loud my husband's got cancer and this
may end bad
it's probably not going to because thank
goodness it's in such a sensitive place
that we're able to catch it early and so
far everybody's on the up and up and
they are unable to detect anything
and we know that the absence of proof
isn't the proof of absence but right now
we are celebrating like crazy because
what a win
yeah you see what i'm saying
yeah i think
right now like
we we have a great support system but
like
everyone is trying to be super
supportive and positive in the only way
that they know how and so nobody says
things like that like nobody says
like yeah this really sucks and he could
die like nobody says that everyone's
just like oh he's 29 he's healthy he's
gonna be fine like everything's gonna be
fine okay so
just listening to you
in a minute and a half
just me saying that sentence out loud
instantly brought tears to your eyes
and then right now i can hear it in you
your shoulders have dropped
and then you start to get pissed why are
you pissed because your husband's
freaking got cancer when he's 29 it's
not supposed to happen like that
yeah
and if you don't deal with the anger and
i don't say deal with it to get rid of
it if you don't acknowledge it
pull up a chair
it's you're supposed to be angry
it's ridiculous
you look around at all your other
knuckleheaded friends and their stupid
husbands and they don't have cancer
you know what i mean yeah
yeah and bladder cancer what an uh like
i've got a family member right now with
with bladder cancer that's a humiliating
cancer
a lot of people digging around in the
goods you know what i mean yeah i don't
want that i don't go to these
appointments you know what i mean so
yeah yeah pull up a chair
now here's a couple of things that i've
seen walking alongside folks number one
you suddenly found yourself you alone
responsible for all the other people's
well-being around you
yup cause oh my gosh he's got kit and
suddenly you're trying to take care of
everybody else
not just him but like aunt martha and
his mom and your friends oh and now it's
their thing and now they're posting on
their instagram walls pray for dan
because dan's go and you're just like
what do you you know what i mean
yeah number two
you don't have permission to laugh
you don't have permission to crack up to
be silly
to when he screws up the dishes
even though he's wheeling a bag behind
him to go will you do the dishes right
you know what i mean
you haven't been touched
other than desperation hugs
you
have a right to
have your full range of hurt and your
full range of joy
and every time you laugh and you start
to feel guilty because oh yeah he had
cancer
just that's when you stop that thought
train just stop it and go nope i get to
laugh
you know what else i get
that dude when he gets up takes the cold
peas off of his
off the
off the unit
he's gonna vacuum because he can do it
you know what i mean
yeah
so don't fall into the guilt trap of his
needs are more important than your needs
both of your needs matter here because
here's why
he needs you to be strong and you can
only be strong if your needs are met too
okay
yeah
so decide what the next two weeks we're
gonna let's do this in bite-sized chunks
let's get to the next three months and
let's get to the next three months and
let's get to the next three months
all right
and
as best we can
uh you may have heard me say this i
don't know if i've ever said it on this
show i've said it before but um so i
used to catastrophize financial stuff
all the time
wildly so
and um i'm just just smart enough to get
myself into a hole that i can't get
myself out of
and i would
write these things out and i'd find
another article another article another
article there's always somebody
confirming what i thought and so i would
meet with cfos i would meet with all
kinds of folk i had access to some fancy
pants money people and
none of them would if they said things
are going to be okay i would say well
you're dumb and so i got myself into
this spiral right the doctors probably
looked at you and smiled and said we got
it and you were like yeah but what if
you didn't right this is a oncologist
this is their profession this is who
they are and what they do
and they are trained not to give false
hope but you
kirsten the 29 year old wonder kid knows
more than the surgeons right
more than the doctors you're like yeah
but you probably what if you missed so
here we are
i had a buddy and he gave me this line
and it changed my life he's one of my
best friends on the planet
so he's a banker and i sat down i was
working through all the money stuff with
him i was like what about this what
about this what about this what about
this and here's his line he finally
looked at me and said john i don't have
a meteorite plan
i said what do you mean
and he said i got savings
i got rental homes i got investments i
don't owe anybody anything i got this i
got that
but if we get hit by a meteorite i will
deal with that then
if the u.s dollar just evaporates and
goes away and everybody's trading
digital art picture nfts for food i will
deal with that then because we'll have
way other problems right
so yeah i tell you
you can't have a meteorite plan
so what does it plan her i know you are
i know you are and part of this the
spiritual exercise here is opening those
tight hands
yeah
and not shove so we're going to plan but
we're playing for two weeks what do two
weeks look like what do i need in the
next two weeks
what does he need in the next two weeks
how can we meet each other's needs and
for the things that we can't
maybe he's got to go to bed at eight
o'clock cause he's still wiped out
awesome
two nights a week after you're in bed
i'm gonna go hang out with my
girlfriends and we're gonna laugh like
crazy
you know what i mean
yeah
you staying up at after he goes to bed
at eight staying up till midnight
researching crazy medical journals is
not helping
no it doesn't
no it just dumps gasoline on your face
all right
so yes it does be gracious with your
body when it spins up
you almost
lost the wind in your lungs
you should be scared
yeah and
you can spray him with a water bottle
you can still do something sexy you can
still laugh at him you can still shove
him unless he's gonna fall over don't do
that if he's gonna fall over
you can still make jokes whatever
okay it's both end
yeah
and there may be something healing about
if you haven't already
holding his hands and looking him in the
eye
and saying the words i don't want you to
die
and him saying i don't want to die
either and you saying i need you here
say those words out loud and look him in
the eye
and then let him know we're in this
together
and by the way nice place to get cancer
dude
right
i know it's crazy he has no family
history of any like anything like this
it's just like out of the blue
yeah i know and hey don't get struck by
lightning yes you did you diss yes don't
go don't spend your energy mining for
why and where it is it is
trust your doctors
they apparently really good
trust your doctors
plan for two weeks and then plan for the
next two weeks and plan for the next two
weeks and make sure you're a part of
that planning too what do you need
make sure you're eating make sure you're
sleeping make sure you're turning off
the stupid devices and not going down
rabbit holes and watching youtube clips
of some knucklehead like in an abandoned
warehouse like with the expose on
chemotherapy shut up with all that
hold that man's hand
and let that man hold your hand
and weep with him and laugh like crazy
and then when the three months comes up
your heart's gonna race you're gonna get
sick you're probably gonna throw up
you're not gonna want to eat you're
gonna get diarrhea all those things and
that's okay
and then you're gonna have the next two
weeks so the next two weeks after that
the next two weeks after that you're
gonna plan for the next three-month
meeting
you're in it now you're in it let your
body love you and also know when to tell
your body ah i'm not doing that we're
not going down that road
i'm choosing a good day today